moins d'argent dans les caisses des
régions l'an prochain le premier
ministre edouard philippe a demandé hier
aux présidents des régions de faire des
efforts certains ont suspendu le
dialogue avec le gouvernement bonjour
marie-guite dufay
pour bien comprendre l'état vous
demandons de faire ces efforts 450
millions ont été promis par manuel valls
un transfert de compétences entre
départements et régions ce qui vous
fâchent ce qu'on vous dit la fin
septembre
vous n'aurez pas ces crédits dès 2018 ce
qui nous fâche c'est que les engagements
ne sont pas tenus
qu'il faille faire des économies qu'il
faille faire attention à la dépense
publique
ça c'est clair net et partager mais nous
avions convenu l'an dernier que parce
que nous allions avoir des charges
venant des départements pour payer le
développement économique
assuré de l'appui aux entreprises
industrielles artisanales aux
exploitations agricoles des dépenses qui
était assurée par les départements et
qui maintenant sont assurés par les
régions du fait de la loi
nous avions demandé une compensation
financière et cette confusion en guise
de compensation financière elle est de
450 millions niveau national est de 20
millions pour notre région et nous avons
appris subrepticement que ces 450
millions seraient ôter des recettes que
l'état va nous accorder l'année
prochaine donc l'engagement n'est pas
inclus est par ailleurs le président de
la république avait dit que pour l'année
qui venait il n'y aurait aucune baisse
de dotation pour les collectivités ton
qu'on n'avait pas signé un pacte où on
expliqué à l'état comment on allait
organiser nos dépenses donc plutôt
proche du gouvernement de mâcon vous lui
dites tout ça vous l'avez dit clairement
les yeux dans les yeux ah mais je me
suis associé à la colère de tous mes
collègues hier il n'y avait pas de
différence d'un président d'exécutif à
l'autre parce que nous sommes surtout
vraiment extrêmement ébranlé de voir que
la parole de l'état n'ait pas tenu c'est
pas l'histoire de faire des économies
c'est pas du tout ça le sujet c'est que
la parole de l'état n'ait pas tenu
il ya eu un engagement l'an dernier il
ya eu un deuxième engagement cette année
ils ne sont pas tenus
et nous avons le sentiment doux
désinvolture de l'état mais quand je dis
l'état c'est l'état central c'est les
administrations centrales
c'est par l'état ici en région et donc
je fais très attention parce que il a
été décidé de rompre tout dialogue avec
l'état dans le cadre de la conférence
nationale des territoires qu'a mise en
oeuvre et manuel valls 1 emmanuel macron
la conférence nationale des territoires
et moi je souhaite que sur notre
territoire
dans notre région le dialogue avec les
préfets le dialogue avec la préfète de
région soit maintenue parce que c'est un
très bon dialogue les préfets
connaissent nos soucis connaissent nos
préoccupations
il ne faut pas voir la chaise vide merci
pour ces explications mérites du fait